you
ivorie one is cherry here's another cool
chess puzzle that I'd like to share with
you it's been a while since I added to
this playlist number 16 now as usual I
suggest you spend some time and trying
to work these puzzles out nice little
miniature calculation exercise it's
white to move and it's up to you to try
and find the best continuation okay the
solution to this one is one that I think
most chess players will really like I
certainly did and if you got it
I'm sure it's gonna feel really good the
first move here is to play f5 and black
continues to push the apon doing
something other than that like capturing
will result in both sides pretty much
queening and it'll actually turn out
where white will have the fun let's just
say after h6 I can capture white pushes
here notice capturing here would not be
a good idea because when black promotes
they will be there to stop white from
promoting so therefore white could just
bypass and black promotes but then white
promotes with check and has all the fun
this will end it as a draw
short story here's that on f5 capturing
doesn't really help black out and so
black bushes
- here we capture on g6 pushing here is
not working because black intake and
after the recapture the king is there in
time to hunt the pond down so we capture
on g6 black continues to push and we
pretty much I mean with this capture
here we're giving up on any idea to try
and get a queen so what is the idea
exactly how cool is this king g4 see
what's happening here
black promotes in/out King to h5 clearly
have an endgame study on our hands I
have no idea who composed this if you
have that information feel free to share
with me and I'll be sure to update the
title and description to this video
white is boxing himself in a little self
stalemate going on with the King and
white pawns and there's nothing black
can do to prevent this it'll take black
three moves before the Queen key get
here so you attack the King about by
that time it'll already be stalemate on
a check we play g4 and pick your
favorite spot to go with the Queen
anything besides Queen takes pawn will
be a stalemate a self stalemate just huh
starting with this f5 advance and
capturing on g6 knowing that we're not
going to be able to push through and get
a queen in time you have to you had to
work that out and recognize this
formation where you can box your king in
and there's just nothing that black can
do I know I came over to d1 but I mean
what else is there to do Queen here g4
Queen here
it's stalemate no legal moves for white
pretty cool one um feel free to share
what your thoughts are on this whenever
I come across a a neat little puzzle
like this it's always on my mind to
maybe share in this playlist and I think
that this is a fitting one for it so as
usual feel free to leave any feedback
let me know what you think of this one
and I hope you enjoyed it that's all for
now take care bye to me it's the coolest
puzzle I've ever seen it's white to move